tras algo más de cuatro horas reunidos
en estambul
las delegaciones sucre en arena rusa
para los procesos de paz después de
haber empezado este proceso en
bielorrusia pasarlo online y ahora
empezaron a estambul han hablado de
estas charlas como un proceso
constructivo y positivo que puedes
seguir en el futuro ya han establecido
los puntos básicos para continuar con
estas asociaciones lo ha hecho sobre
todo el jefe de la relación ucraniana
que ha explicado los dos grandes puntos
bases a partir de los cuales ucrania
quiere continuar con estas negociaciones
el primero de ellos es la neutralidad de
ucrania en respecto que lo que respecta
a la otan un cannes se compromete a no
pedir la entrada a este a esta unión
transa lácticas y recibe el compromiso
de varios países extranjeros de proteger
y defender a ucrania en caso de una
nueva ofensiva militar y una nueva
ocupación con compasión en contra de su
propio territorio estos países podrían
ser varios incluyendo los eeuu gran
bretaña francia alemania y turquía
además también este jefe de relación
delegación ucraniana ha establecido un
periodo de 15 años futuros en los que
ucrania pediría estudiar con rusia el
futuro de la península de crimea ocupada
por rusia desde 2014 y ucrania se
comprometió durante en estos 15 años no
atacar y no llevar a cabo ninguna
operación militar en contra de este
territorio además por su parte el jefe
de la delegación rusa ha sido mucho más
escueto en lo que respecta a lo que ha
comentado sobre esta reunión ha dicho
que ha sido muy constructiva como ya
hemos ya venimos comentando pero sobre
todo ha dicho que para para facilitar
que estas negociaciones puedan continuar
y rusia se compromete a frenar y a parar
sobre todo frenando sus ofensivas en la
capital ucraniana kiev y la ciudad de
herning y turquía a quien está
facilitando estas conversaciones de
espera que puedan continuar en un futuro
y van a hacerlo mañana no van a hacerlo
pero sí que en las próximas semanas
esperan que ucrania rusa puedan reunirse
otra vez y continuar con estas
negociaciones que de momento parece que
pueden ir a buen puerto